[Musique]
bonjour à tous nos amis à poils et à
plumes c'est miss plume et nous vous
souhaitons la bienvenue dans ce premier
épisode de kick effet la bestiole ce
sera peut-être aussi le dernier épisode
qui se tout dépend si ça vous plaît ou
non et si je tombe sur d'autres petites
vidéos du même style
car le sujet de ce qu'est café la
bestiole c'est l'analyse des
comportements avions et pour cela nous
avons besoin d'un support visuel en
l'occurrence une vidéo
aujourd'hui nous allons nous concentrer
sur une espèce de sitel d'amérique du
nord site à caroline n 6
si vous n'êtes pas familier d'espèce ce
n'est pas bien grave car nos cités
européennes ont plus ou moins le même
comportement et vous n'avez pas non plus
besoin d'être des cracks en éthologie
pour cet exercice
le but c'est d'essayer de comprendre ce
qui se passe dans la vidéo qui va suivre
et d'en déduire ce que l'oiseau essaie
de faire vous êtes prêts c'est parti
[Musique]
alors j'imagine que vous avez déjà
quelques idées et si vous n'en avez pas
ce n'est pas bien grave je vais vous
donner une liste comme pour un qcm et
vous allez pouvoir choisir la réponse
qu'il vous semble la plus appropriée
alors la question du jour est donc mais
que fait cet oiseau petit il fait sécher
s'est elle comme le cormoran petit b il
protège son repas il ya certainement une
menace quelque part petit c ils dansent
pour sa promise il ya une jolie femelle
un petit peu plus loin que ty et il fait
ses étirements matinaux le sport c'est
important voilà donc prenez le temps de
réfléchir pendant ce temps moi je vous
remet la vidéo
petite astuce avant qu'on redémarre
regardez bien l'environnement de
l'oiseau le contexte c'est ce qu'il ya
de plus important
[Musique]
ici
et nous revoilà donc devant ce petit
quizz si vous voulez avoir un peu plus
de temps pour réfléchir peut mettre sur
pause là maintenant tout de suite et
pour les autres on va passer aux
résultats la bonne réponse était donc la
baie il protège son repas bravo à ceux
qui avaient trouvé il y avait deux
indices dans la vidéo le premier ici ce
que vous voyez passer sur le côté
accroché au tronc c'est un écureuil en
l'occurrence un tamis enrayer un petit
écureuil nord américain aussi appelée
chipmunks ça vous dit quelque chose
malgré sa petite taille le tamia est
deux fois plus grand que la sittelle et
donc représente certainement une menace
pour elle imaginez vous à sa place quand
on est en face d'un animal deux fois
plus grand que nous on a tendance à ne
pas farid hier et avec raison
l'autre indice ce sont les graines
disposés sur le tronc la cité elle a vu
les graines de long car les oiseaux ont
généralement une très bonne vue elle se
pose à côté et essaie donc de décourager
les éventuels pique assiette qui
pourrait venir lui ravir son repas et
oui la nature ce n'est pas que payet et
couchers de soleil magnifique c'est
surtout un combat de tous les jours
simplement pour pouvoir dicter ce que
vous voyez dans cette vidéo c'est donc
un réseau essayant de paraître le plus
gros et le plus intimidant possible pour
décourager les curieux de venir lui
voler son repas et cette posture avec
les l étendue sert simplement à
augmenter sa taille un peu comme le font
aussi les ebooks quand ils se sentent
menacés
[Musique]
et voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui
dites moi si ça vous a plu ici oui je
ferai certainement d'autres vidéos au
gré de mes trouvailles sur la toile à
bientôt pour de nouvelles aventures avec
des plumes
[Musique]